the Peshmerga are the fighting force of
Iraq's Kurds and ethnic minority they've
been battling for the independence of
their people since the fall of the
Ottoman Empire the name Peshmerga means
those who confront death they have a
reputation for bravery and are seen as
an elite military force they worked with
the CIA against Saddam Hussein who
killed at least 100,000 Kurds using
chemical weapons attacks and
assassinations lately their weapons have
proved no match for the Islamic state
group who are using heavy artillery that
they seized from the Iraqi army which by
the way Iraq got from the US but because
the Peshmerga are seen as one of the
only forces that has a chance at
defeating the Islamic state group
the US has decided to arm them
you